we want to bring you an update in the
meantime on a story we're following
overseas Britain's Prime Minister is in
intensive care this morning after his
fight with the coronavirus took a
troubling turn Boris Johnson a key US
ally was moved to the ICU last evening
he was taken to the hospital initially
on Sunday after persistent fever more
than a week after testing positive
Elizabeth Palmer reports from London
Britain's Prime Minister spent the night
in intensive care getting oxygen but
Downing Street says he's not on a
ventilator late last week Boris Johnson
emerged briefly from his residence to
applaud health workers but in a Twitter
video admitted he wasn't well enough yet
to end his isolation alas I still have
one of the symptoms of - symptom of I
have a temperature that was clearly an
understatement 48 hours later Johnson
was in the hospital early in the
outbreak he fronted the UK campaign to
promote hand-washing but also boasted
about shaking hands with coronavirus
patients which suggests multiple
exposures Johnson works to stay fit he's
a keen cyclist and tennis player but
he's also 55 years old and male which
elevates his risk of complications from
coronavirus his pregnant partner Kerry
Simon's had coronavirus symptoms
- but she's recovering Boris Johnson has
handed over the running of the UK
government to Dominic rabe who's the
foreign secretary as Britain passes
another grim milestone in this pandemic
more than 5,000 people have now died
here although there is some evidence
that the spread of the infection may
peak this coming week Anthony Elizabeth
Palmer in London Thank You Liz